my record is clear.
when times are difficult in this country,
I will always protect the most vulnerable.
that is the values of our compassionate party.
we did it in COVID and we will do that again.
Mr Speaker, he says he'll protect the most vulnerable.
let's test that.
the government currently allows
very rich people to live here
but register abroad for tax purposes.
well, Mr Speaker,
I have been honest.
we will have to take difficult decisions to restore
economic stability and confidence.
and my honorable friend
the Chancellor
will set that out in an awesome statement in just
a few weeks.
pretends he's on the side of working people,
but in private
he says something very different.
over the summer,
he was secretly recorded
at a garden party in Tunbridge Wells
boasting to a group of Tori members
that he personally moved money away from deprived areas
to wealthy places instead.
rather than apologize
or pretend that he meant something else,
why doesn't he now do the right thing
and undo the changes that he made
to those funding formulas?
I'm the first to admit that mistakes were made,
and that's the reason I am standing here.
but that is the difference between him and Meather.
when he ran for leader,
he promised his policy
he would borrow billions and billions of pounds.
I told the truth
for the good of the country.
he told his party what it wanted to hear.
leadership is not selling fairy tales
it is confronting challenges
and that is the leadership
the British people will get from this government.